how did Ty Chrisley get 12 years in
prison and Jen Shaw gets six and a half
you have someone who has victims victims
who have provided victim statements they
were over the age of 55. do the Chrisley
slams fellow reality star Jen Shaw as
her and her husband Todd report to
federal prison to start serving their
sentence so we're standing by our truth
that it is not guilty there are no
victims there were no victim statements
received to our knowledge exactly we
made a commitment that we were not going
to give up our daughter Savannah's
unlocked podcast recorded one week
before Julie surrendered to prison the
Chrisley Knows Best star opened up and I
just want to say to everyone that we
thank you we thank you for your
continued prayers and your support last
year the couple was found guilty of bank
fraud and tax evasion prosecutors said
Todd and Julie took out over 30 million
dollars in fraudulent bank loans to fund
their lavish lifestyle we grew up in a
very small rural town and our main home
is 30 000 square feet I have two
dishwashers which is a must if you can
possibly have it meanwhile in the Bravo
verse what do you want to say to the
family The Real Housewives of Salt Lake
City Star got the same critique in court
I have an entire staff that works for me
every day they're called the Shah Squad
Jen was sentenced to six and a half
years in prison after pleading guilty to
committing wire fraud
there were
hundreds of victims who were elderly as
the mother-daughter Duo sees it the
Chrisley's punishments don't fit their
alleged crimes there were so many
different things and she got six and a
half years make that make sense because
then on the other side you have someone
who has not admitted to guilt
and who will stand firm in that right
there there are no Victory there were no
victim statements there were no victim
statements read there were no victim
statements received to our knowledge
exactly if only people knew that things
that they did for people on a day-to-day
basis they're the two most giving people
I think I've ever met my entire life
another devastating detail the podcast
was recorded on Julie's 50th birthday I
love you I love you you are the greatest
human being I think I've ever met I've
never seen two people my parents be so
steadfast in their faith in the end the
truth will prevail may get harder before
it gets easier but we have faith and
Savannah's looking to adopt her mom's
positive attitude as she navigates this
next chapter hopefully I will learn some
of your um
what is it your abilities of just
keeping my mouth shut a little more just
be a little nicer Savannah a little
nicer a little Kinder and I'm just gonna
keep that way for now because frankly
well it's life so until next time I love
you Mama I love you
[Music]